Chris Waters here with a Gamespot news
update Not only was it just announced
that Dark Souls 2 is getting some brand
new content but it was also revealed
that an updated version of the game is
coming to Playstation 4 Xbox One and
PC titled Dark Souls 2 scholar of the
first sin the game will not only include
all of the Lost crowns DLC currently
available for the game it will also add
quote an array of all new content it be
available April 7th next year for Xbox
One PlayStation 4 and for directx11 PCs
and includes quote enhanced Graphics in
addition to brand new game content
including an expanded Story featuring
additional in-game events and NPC
characters along with new deadlier
enemies and gameplay improvements if
you're worried that last gen will be
abandoned relax skull of the first sin
will be available for PS3 Xbox 360 and
direct X9 PCS as a compilation that
includes the original game and and all
the DLC missions and in a generous touch
anyone who buys the compilation or owns
the original game will get the new
content through a free update adding
quote an additional NPC to seek out as
well as an expanded story in-game events
improved balance and online matchmaking
functionality so Dark Souls 2 scholar of
the first sin slated to release just two
months after bloodborne's release in
February it's going to be a great new
year for from software fans and we'll
have all the news for you right here on
gamespot.com
newws